[Music]
hey everyone thanks for coming it looks
like quite a busy room so essentially
today I'm going to be talking about ways
in which you can build robust machine
learning systems so stuff that's running
in production making decisions affecting
customers and you could also title this
talk basically all the fingers and way
which your machine learning system will
fail that I've unfortunately experienced
so what is what is ravelin and Who am I
so I'm a co-founder and machine learning
engineer a travelin ravelin is a company
that ingests data from customers and
from clients to help them protect
merchants against credit card fraud so
if you are an app or your business and
you take credit card payments an
unfortunate reality of life is that
there'll be some level of fraud
associated with that from people
stealing credit cards and using them to
transact in your business so we use
machine learning to understand the
behavior of these people and to block
them from using your service so you
never have to pay the fees in the first
place
so machine learning forms a core part of
the product and essentially is like the
very you know the very thing that we are
selling and some of the clients that use
us are delivery
easy taxi halo and a bunch more so a
little about the specific problem that I
focus on my day job credit card fraud is
a really big deal as I'm sure you know
I'm I'm going to hazard a guess that
almost everyone here has been a victim
of credit card fraud at some point in
their life basically an adversary will
steal your credit card details this will
be through things like data breaches
it'll be through insecure you know you
having browser on insecure connections
attacks etc and then they'll make a
purchase using that card this is bad for
you but ultimately you get the money
back so it's kind of you know it sucks
but eventually you'll get paid back it's
a lot worse for the merchants that you
bought the goods from so if you bought a
let's say you bought a TV from Dixon's
if you're if the fraudster buys a TV
from Dixon's you notice that that that
that was a fraudulent purchase you'll
get your
back unfortunately Dixons is out a TV
and the cost of the whole TV so they
they have to cover the loss plus a 15 to
20 pound charge back fee on top of that
problem they may do they might not a lot
of people don't and so it's not often
clear who pays for that fraud like most
people think the bank pays for it most
people think these or Amex pay for it
but most of the times it's the merchant
that pays for it so if you're a low
margin business so you make five percent
or two percent off an order if you make
two percent off an order one one
fraudulent order is basically worth
fifty good orders to get back up to
where you originally were so you can
completely wipe out your revenue in one
of these one of these situations so it's
adversarial so foresters are constantly
trying to figure out what your machine
learning system is doing and try and get
around it so it's an interesting problem
in that case there's a very true
precision recall trade-off here
so false nog false negatives versus
false positives is a really big deal
false positives are basically all of the
fraud checks that you'll of probably
experienced as a customer like you flew
to America you used your card in America
the bank's thinks you're a terrible
fraudster false negatives are where you
don't spot the fraud that did happen and
there's a very kind of fun tension
between this you want to stop some level
of fraud but you don't want to stop good
customers at the expense of stopping
that fraud and mistakes cost lots and
lots of money so I'm kind of here to
talk about software engineering I kind
of describe myself as a software
engineer that does machine learning as
opposed to kind of machine learning
researcher so we think about software
engineering we kind of build functions
with some level of determinism and we
kind of try and prove them correct
through testing and through all these
various offline techniques so if you
imagine you're writing sort of a lecture
or a parser there's a very kind of small
world in which you've constructed where
there's valid input and there's invalid
input and you kind of get to decide the
parameters of that world and there's
there's kind of a sort of inbuilt sense
of guilt and worry if you don't test
your code when it comes to just like
building you know traditional software
machine learning is kind of a whole
other ballgame I think we learn
functions from snap
snap shots so just from data directly
truth is usually fuzzy and truth is
always subject to kind of usually the
past behavior of your system as well so
it's a lot lot harder and I think the
kind of test coverage and what's
acceptable to ship is kind of usually a
lot less robust and machine learning
systems are often treated as a very much
a special snowflake when it comes to to
shipping things and I think most
software engineers would probably be
horrified at the the current state
machine learning testing tooling
deployment development etc and the key
point is we learn models and models are
just views of the world that we've
snapshotted into data they're not magic
they're not free of biases and they're
definitely they definitely need to be
respected so why is running these sorts
of systems hard I'd say there's really
high base complexity in doing so these
systems are very complex by design the
bugs that happen with them are usually
silent and for you know kind of silent
performance degradation so I kind of
compare them to data corruption bugs on
hard disks like you won't about the
problem until it's too too late you also
train your models as if they have no
impact on the future when the very point
of the system that you're building is to
have some impact on the future so the
current decisions you're making you're
going to impact the labels that you get
in the future and we also kind of
sometimes ignore that and the loss
function that we train for doesn't
really usually represent the true goal
so like so you want to train for
engagement or for user happiness you
can't really express that as a loss
function so we end up trying to train on
log loss or we train on you know a very
carefully constructed loss function and
it's not often clear that that's
actually what we wanted to achieve in
the first place when we build the system
so how can we stop machine learning
systems from being this kind of special
snowflake status and more just like
normal kind of boring software wouldn't
it be great if we can take things from
software engineering that allows us to
speed refactor and upgrade with ease and
apply them to machine learning and
because I think it's important to
realize that for a lot of people machine
learning is just an implementation
detail of the system that
building if you abstract away everything
to do with machine learning usually
you're just providing some kind of score
function which is like given some
customer data please tell me how likely
they are to be a fraud store how likely
they are to click on this ad it's not
really obvious to your end-users that
you have to use machine learning to do
any of that so when machine learning
fails you don't have a valid excuse of
you know some future technical reason
around machine learning why it failed
because they ultimately don't care at
the end of it I would say that the
advice that I'm giving in this talk is
around kind of medium to highly complex
machine learning systems so if you're
just you know if you're building kind of
these basic basic simple systems then
you can kind of disregard a lot of a lot
of what I'm talking about but I'm
talking about kind of time-dependent
real world interacting machine learning
systems and and that's kind of where a
lot of this advice comes from so I want
to talk about techniques that you can
use when training your models to
basically ensure that they are robust
and they love the things that you want
them to learn I don't mean like how
should you optimize high parameters or
how many folds of cross-validation are
needed it's kind of a lot more simple
than that I want to talk about how do we
make sure that the world that we present
the model is the actual view of the
world that we want to learn and this is
the fuzziest questions come out and
they're you kind of need good judgment
but I usually get good at this through
kind of black magic and a lot of burnt
fingers so ultimately in kind of
classification problems labels are the
ultimate ground you know sort of truth
of what we're trying to learn but I'm
truth is an approximate notion in
machine learning systems so if we think
about feedback loops in machine learning
systems say you have a flow prediction
system like we do one of the things that
we do is to prevent transactions that we
think of Rajan because obviously that's
the whole point of ravelin but when you
say someone is a fraud someone is likely
to be a fraudster you'll unblock them
from ever making a transaction
you then lose the possibility of getting
that label back about whether they
actually were a Ford store or not so you
have to remember that like the labels
that you are getting in are a function
of the essentially a function of the
entire system that you've built so far
and if you think about the fraud that's
still coming in is the hardest fraud to
predict because it's the four that you
didn't catch with your system so you
have to you very much have to like be
aware of this all of the time it's the
same in ad tech I've never worked in it
but the ads that you present to a user
are you know the probability of clicking
on an ad is a function of how
prominently that advertisement has been
displayed to the user and you have to be
able to control for this using using
your training techniques but I don't
have much experience with advertising
one of the biggest pains of my day job
is the fact that the labels that we get
back from fraud are super super delayed
so if I if I'm a fraud state and I
commit fraud today there's a kind of
probability distribution over how many
days it will take you to detect that
fraud on your credit card statement and
then the days after that it will flow
through the global financial system and
then days after that will eventually get
back to the to the PST where the
original payment came from so like this
can easily take it up two to three
months for a label to reach traveling
from when we've made a decision so when
you're thinking about training your
models if you train on data from the
last month or two you haven't received
the labels for the last month or two
because some of those some of those
transactions that haven't appeared as
fraudulent yet are fraudulent that you
haven't simply got the label for them so
you then have to kind of discard a
certain amount of your training data to
be able to deal with that there's also
the notion of kind of implicit versus
explicit labels like hints versus actual
true ground truth so I don't know if
you've heard of a system called 3d
secure in the UK it will be the system
that you have been kind of subjected to
you know you have to remember kind of
your mother
you know your grandmother's maiden name
and the you know the eye color of your
cat or all these various things and
people
if you
and it sucks but people go through that
and usually going through that is a
decent kind of hint towards the fact
that if you pass 3d secure and Ravel and
thought you were a fraud stud then maybe
we should update our views to take
account of that fact and I'm sure that
you know in in recommendations and all
of these other sorts of fields you have
like clicks non clicks looking at you
know viewed it but didn't dink click all
of these sorts of hints which you can
use to construct labels but are not true
labels in the in the sense of the term
and you should never really
underestimate the importance of good
labels basically every problem I've
faced a travellin has been due to bad
labeling or incomplete labeling so
you'll have certain subject subsections
of your data that never got labeled due
to something your system was doing that
deprioritize them from like actually
getting a true label and you just always
need to be keeping an eye on this it's
basically where everything goes wrong so
how do you are looking at your training
data you probably need some kind of time
machine if you're doing time dependent
modeling so if you think about time
leakage we when we train for fraud we
have to only take what we knew at time X
to make that prediction we can't use
stuff we can't use information that we
know now otherwise all we'll do is train
our machine learning model to wait up
until you know a very long time period
and then say oh yeah they're a fraudster
because they you know did three
fraudulent transactions and that's
definitely not what we want to do as I
said earlier we have to filter out some
of our training data and this is like
okay this is a bad thing to do a lot of
the time because you're just explicitly
biasing the data that you train on but
we have to take out the last month or
two because it contains bad labels it we
also have to take out certain there is
other sorts of things where we think
that like the kind of label coverage is
too bad and we just rather not train on
them at all because we have enough data
to train models as it stands we don't
need to kind of contaminate our training
set with them and then sampling is like
sometimes computationally necessary
there's
if the above is like here be dragons
there's like a few dragons and this one
it's not it's not super bad but it's
it's sometimes painful because you have
to figure out things that approximately
represent what you're doing in life but
aren't you don't want to buy a training
set too much effectively so if you've if
you kind of followed these techniques
when using when dealing with your
training data I kind of want to talk
about testing your end-to-end system so
not testing in terms of performance on
test sets but in terms of how does the
system work and to end like an
integration test so machine learning is
kind of unique and well relatively
unique and the fact that it's made up of
like code so the code use to extract
some features and the actual data used
to extract those features and in my
experience you should assume that kind
of either-or broken unless you actually
test them so you usually have some kind
of invariant in your data which is like
this must go up in time with customer
the average must be one all of these
sorts of things they're usually like
hilariously wrong until you've actually
gone in and had a look at them so you
should you should really be like testing
your data cyllid enguarde is a panda's
library for testing invariants things
must be within certain bounds etc we we
just wrote a simple one which is kind of
more tailored to what we do it but
they're very simple because pandas has a
very nice API for for explaining all of
this stuff but it's it's kind of just
the constant sense of paranoia or
challenge or like drill into people is
that given the complexity of these
things you should be assuming things are
broken until you've kind of tested them
to make sure that they're not otherwise
so testing models is an interesting
problem because there's some you know
there's some randomness when it comes to
doing this it's also models or a
function of data so how do you test data
like it's kind of a bit complicated as I
start to figure out how you do that one
thing that we found really useful is to
have these sort of assertion sets or
things that ravelin would be extreme
embarrass to get wrong and we pulled
these out during training time and we
say okay this is effectively a unit test
like an assert true sort of thing if we
if we are a fashion company we're trying
to stop blue dresses and the bluest of
blue dresses comes off as red then it
doesn't matter what our test sets
performance or any of these other
metrics means something is really really
badly broken and we can go back to the
start and figure out why that is so we
found this super useful we also recently
started generating sort of synthetic
data sets so if you have more complex
sort of nonlinear models you kind of you
want to be able to figure out what your
worst case scenario is so if you think
of fraud if someone has added three
hundred credit cards to their account in
ten minutes
and spent a hundred thousand pounds it
would be very bad if ravelin did not
spot that and we don't really see these
examples in our training set because you
know hopefully we're a bit better than
that but uh but we can generate
synthetic data to know what we would do
if these sorts of very very bad
worst-case scenarios were to happen I
think it's very useful to do because
then you can start building some level
of confidence and assertions about
real-world things that you expect your
model to do without having to kind of
find them in your training set and if
you have a really really complex system
with loads and loads of features and
this might be harder to do but I would
recommend it if you can do it and
inspecting your most misclassified
examples this is like where your model
is desperately trying to tell you like
there is something wrong here this
person is mislabeled there is some
basically either your model is very very
bad or it's trying to tell you something
and this is where a lot of the bugs that
I've seen have come out and it's just
like pure miss labeling of examples it's
just very interesting this is where like
a lot of your bugs will kind of manifest
themselves as your models sort of
desperately trying to tell you that
something's wrong so how do you make
sure when you deploy models that they're
actually any good are they better than
the previous models that's quite hard to
it's quite hard to know but you should
have different you should probably have
some
good sense of it by this point the this
point you're switching environments
usually so you're going from offline to
online and you'll sometimes also
switching data sources as well so you
should be kind of rightfully paranoid at
this point is like okay do any of these
for you know this two-by-two matrix
actually match up hopefully they all do
but if none of them do then like you're
you're kind of screwed so one of the
things that has been really useful
before we even press deploy on a model
is the idea of sort of model provenance
so given that we have this kind of bit
of code that has been learnt from data
we need to be able to trace that back
and figure out okay given that it's the
subset of all of these other things like
let's make it so we can actually go back
in time and figure out what did it so
I'm who trained the model who can we go
and shelter if things go wrong when was
it trained and on wolcott hash so what
sort of what were the parameters of the
models that were being used at that time
which raw data was used where can we
find it can we reproduce the whole the
whole end-to-end system which features
were used which hyper amateurs and kind
of really importantly what was like
training test performance but like what
is the inference what is the
distribution of the scores look like so
if your distribution offline is super
different to online then something's up
and and we just stick these in a Python
dictionary and kind of ship them out
because if you can access them
programmatically you can then start
asking more interesting questions of
your system being able to say okay what
are all the what are all the models that
are in production that have a deviation
from the original distribution of more
than X this is kind of invaluable for
being able to figure out basically when
things go wrong so when you want to ship
models I would really really encourage
you to not say please go and rebuild
this you know MATLAB or our model in
Java and come back to me in two months
and let me know how it went I would
really try and use the same language the
same frameworks the same everything to
go from offline research work to offline
production to online sort of put
action and you really want to do couple
the data source that you have from the
way that you compute features on that
data so what I mean by that is that the
way we do it ravelin is we have the same
we have sort of a go online service that
takes a that the interface is simply
just give me all of the features about
this customer and given these sorts of
these sorts of our fields of data so
transactions and orders and cards and
then when we do that online we go and
get this stuff from a Postgres database
and give it to that function and back on
the features when we do it offline we go
and get the data from bigquery because
it's much bigger than we can paralyze it
but the code that computes the features
doesn't know what where the data is
coming from so it means that we've kind
of eliminated at least one of the rows
and that matrix of the the way that we
calculate features being any different
which has made stuff a lot more easy to
debug because we basically just wiped
away half of the problems that could
happen at that point so when you deploy
it
releasing gradually is always a good
idea just a be testing ramping up
traffic all of these sorts of techniques
just don't go ok the new models going
out now and then change everything
because it never usually goes well so
one technique we found really helpful
and it's just kind of blindingly obvious
is just score them both in the same at
at the same time in life and then just
take the things that have the biggest
differences like you'll find really
really sort of spurious correlations if
your model is learnt to exploit
structure offline that it's not there
online you'll start to see it in this at
this time point and basically this is
where you should kind of be most
paranoid about stuff so as like a more
engineering approach just if you're
going to make some sort of prediction be
that recommendation be that probability
of fraud just store all the raw features
it used and the score that you gave
because you can use these to kind of
unpack what went wrong you can also use
them to as a source of future training
data for other
systems without having to go back and
kind of recompute everything so alerting
instrumentation if you use something
like data dog or Nagi oaths or any of
these any of these platforms just pump
information about the distributions of
schools that you're giving back because
then you can start saying okay well if
if ravelin says more than roughly once
two percent of things are fraud then
ravelin is wrong probably and not you
know the outside world so we can do
alerts on that we can alert the right
people and you know most importantly
measure the actual kind of goal that you
wanted to do in the first place don't
just measure a precision recall and all
of the other associated metrics so
automation and this is kind of one of
the last things I want to talk about but
it's one of the things that we've
invested the most time into a raveling
so we're a team of about kind of four to
five data scientists there's a mixture
of like engineering focus more research
focus but investing a lot of time into
automation has meant that we're able to
basically get away from a lot of the
menial sort of tasks and also you know
stop wasting time waiting for jobs to
finish and also eliminate lots and lots
of sources of bugs that come from not
having automated stuff so I think
everyone's probably been there at some
point when they're training models is
like you have some data set and then
it's like turns into data brackets one
and then you're like eh right this this
is going to be the one and then you put
final on the end of it and then there's
like another final and basically it
always you're always making iterative
improvements to to what you're doing and
I was totally fine
you should be at you should be applauded
for doing so but uh it at the end of it
it makes replication impossible when you
want to figure out what was this trained
on and what were the functions that will
reply to it and if you automate things I
think it just makes you distill what you
care about into into like into processes
so it actually kind of clarifies what it
what are we actually trying to do here
and is there a way in which we can boil
it down into a process and by the fact
that we don't have to sit there you know
during the working day waiting for long
jobs to finish
you can just kick them off when we leave
the office the team is order of
magnitudes more productive simply by
virtue of not having to wait for it and
also not having to figure out bugs that
have caused by you know this sort of
stuff
so I can't talked quite abstractly about
about things so I thought I would go
into a bit of detail so this is what we
do to train a model we get a bunch of
data from bigquery we pull it down
locally we do you know feature
extraction stuff so we pull features
down we sample them we filter them etc
do feature selection high parameter with
my automation and then we actually train
the model and like given that we've
trained this model there's now a lot of
interesting things that you might want
to do to figure out should I deploy it
but a lot of those things are also
easily automatable you can just pull
down the live model that you have you
can pull down the model that you just
trained and you can do a lot of the
stuff that we figured that you'd only
figure out a deployment time just
offline so you can say assuming that you
have a good a good match between online
and offline you can then you can then do
all of this so in the morning we get
this kind of cute slack notification
that says okay I finished training on
the model here's a little HTML report
for you to read so we then just go
through that it's got all of the got all
of the important features it's got all
of the school distributions etc and then
we can figure out okay do we want to
deploy this model or not so it it's very
nice in that we don't have to be kind of
clicking through manual things to get to
do what we actually need to do and then
finally we just save everything to f3 or
to Google Cloud storage because then we
can get back to this at any point in the
future so there was kind of a bit of a
whirlwind tour through through what I've
been through a travelin building this
stuff I'm very happy to answer answer
questions afterwards but to summarize
there's this is what I would do if I was
to sort of do it do it all again I would
just test everything ruthlessly and
start really really simple I kind of
convinced at this point that unit tests
are helpful for figuring out that your
code is correct but they're much more
helpful prevent for preventing
regressions so I wouldn't lean on them
being like
the source of if your test passed then
the system is fine that's definitely not
true but they certainly can't hurt and
paranoia
so models will cheat ruthlessly at
whatever you give them so there's some
kind of hilariously awful stories about
like you know models cheating in the
data that we've given them and then like
if a certain value is above X and
another value is below Y then everyone
is a fraudster for example we you know
thankfully we catch these off line but
basically yeah you should you should
constantly be looking out for this stuff
and then reproduce it reproducibility
and automation is kind of paramount when
you want to build robust systems because
then you can then you can go back and
figure out what went wrong and more
importantly how you can prevent that in
the future and I maybe it was somewhat
of a depressing talk or you should try
and have fun obviously helps you do it
at the same time better very much go
ahead so in that kind of particular so
the question was what is the good way to
figure out if model is cheating or not
we like to think that we would have
caught these in like all of them ahead
of time and the truth is we've never
managed to catch them ahead of time
because they're always so different I
don't think you can do very much apart
from be kind of have your wits about you
if you start seeing strange things
happening in product it's usually in
production like not when we are actually
sending scores live but just kind of
when we're logging scores we'll start
seeing weird things like every new
customer is much is you know nearly
looks very very likely to be a fraudster
and it's like these sorts of things we
you could say oh well yeah new customers
are in reality you kind of just have to
have that sort of sense about you like
no this is the point at which I should
be very paranoid and digging into these
we'll be in the structure of these will
kind of tell you about why it's done so
unfortunately we've never managed to
automate them but uh they are yeah
they're super painful the worst part
hey nice to automate much origami useful
tools for automating the extraction of
information around your model parameters
or or what they can went into it or
exact 30 manual so yes so the question
is have we found any good useful tools
and processes for automating and
figuring out what went into models so we
use Luigi to do a lot of this
orchestration there's other things like
air flow basically just choose the task
manager and stick with it what we've
ended up doing is we we have the sort of
audit record which is that dict that I
said about test performance other stuff
like you know the data that went into it
goes into there basically all of the
useful information about the extraction
goes into this dictionary so we can look
at that in the HTML report and then we
can also look at that programmatically
we haven't found like great tooling for
actual like model deployment and kind of
serving and intersecting these sorts of
things in life so we've just had to
expose them via API is but here people
talk about kind of science ops I think
is a sort of platform for deploying
models but it's we we found tools you
know open-source tools kind of lacking
in this area but they're not too complex
to build either
go to you how do you version our data
and so our data is pretty much immutable
once we've done the extraction so if we
were going to go and do a manual thing
to the data which is like I don't know
say everyone called Steven is now a
fraudster we would then we wouldn't go
and touch that data we would build a new
version of the binary so the version of
the binaries that we use are also
chucked into or the extracted
information and then we would and then
we would put that in sort of in the
model directly but we don't we don't
really do anything around saying this is
like the version of the schema or
whatever it was because the model the
model knows what features it wants so as
long as you don't take features out then
you don't really have those sorts of
them those sorts of compatibility issues
but I don't know if I really answered
your question
yeah we try not to touch things and
they're not you know touch datafiles and
not tell them and tell anyone about it
because that always get leads to bad
things how do you link your prominence
process to the kind of fine art like a
user file so once you kind of deployed
model presumably your client is who we
are happy to run this collection that
you kind of leaked that video so the way
raveling works is that essentially we
would not like it we would not like you
to know if we deployed a new model or
not
apart from better fraud you know lower
chargeback rates and higher and lower
false positive rates so we don't do so
much around asking people but we
definitely super super paranoid and very
much on offline testing before we can do
poor anything goes to production
essentially some are and some are it
really depends on the East Cape sorry I
think you've been waiting
tell me because it'll disease or what
happens at work or homework when you try
to
yeah that's a that's a really good
question so the question was have we had
any difficulty in trying to introduce
these practices get people to use them
and get teams sort of aligned around it
so I would say I would say no but a lot
of these practices were not what we
started with sort of emergent behavior
of having our fingers burnt and then
going okay that was a bad thing that we
did let's not do the bad thing anymore
and then and then this has kind of
become you know I guess we haven't had
any problems introducing it because it's
always been a reaction to a bad thing
and which is which is kind of nice
because no one really needs convincing
at that point so sorry go ahead
yes previously has already been shown to
be probably Internet and is there any
way to capture
whether your albums capture which are
normally together the new strategy
people are using to probe the system
competitor during which then the fact
that these things that you don't get to
know the gentleman so I think the
question was for is constantly evolving
and what you stopped now is not
necessarily what you are going to stop
in the future is there a way to test
against that I'm not really I hope we
haven't kind of we've obviously thought
about it but we haven't you know it's
also a very hard question like how can
you test the behavior of something
against thee against something you don't
know
so we do a lot of we have sort of
infrastructure that will spot things
that are different so if you think about
kind of very high cardinality variables
like emails email providers all of these
sorts of things we have this sort of
online learning infrastructure that
given that you know given some labels
that come in we are able to quickly
react and say okay this this level of
fraudulence has increased very highly to
the point of which like this contributes
a kind of significant amount to your
score but we don't you know apart from
like various anomaly detection
techniques we don't have anything you
know I can't think of anything specific
to to answer I'm afraid sorry go ahead
sure so first question is haften we do
we retrain models it really varies so
like we usually go for anywhere between
like two weeks and two months it kind of
depends on on what we're doing at the
time because there's a huge lag in from
like I said from deploying a model to
getting any feedback on whether that
model is good you can build models that
predict you know given the number of
chargebacks that you've received so far
how good is this model but you kind of
want to wait a little bit of time to see
it bed in before so that's why we don't
do like you know completely like
retraining every night and shipping but
we could but I don't it's not like a
priority for us at the moment and then
for storing model metadata we did the
easiest thing at the time which is just
a pickled stuff out and to load up load
back in we are we're now it right in the
midst of um we have forking a version of
scikit-learn
which is essentially going to deal with
missing values a lot better so there's a
problem in there's a problem in decision
trees which is if this value is if this
value is not present what do I do
so you can build another variable that
says okay it's not here or you can
impute this variable with a very large
sort of negative number what we've tried
to do is we built a technique which will
go from which will go down trees with
the lowest sort of deviation from the
current probability of fraud so
basically don't change your decision too
much given this variable isn't here so
we pickle everything into these models
and we store everything as a dict and
then we can load it all back out
afterwards and we save all those HTML
files and I'm afraid that's the last
question but please come and get me
offers and thanks for coming
[Applause]
[Music]